election 2016 who do you want taking  snaps for our city as mayor how about  the best quarterback of all time or the  sexiest teammate ever to vote Brady for  mayor of gridiron Heights because Roger  Goodell eats farts you know what I've  never eaten a fart and I know that Tom  Brady he has eaten a fart Plus Tom Brady  has poop for his brain so vote for me as  dictator I'm a meme mayor of gridiron  Heights  paid for by the fines that you thought  were going to charity the results are in  and it's a tie dang it why do I allow  ties sad we lost but at least you beat  us Andrew Luck you're the nicest guy  ever who me  golly shucks not nicer than you Aaron  Rodgers why don't we find out with a  nice guy contest why hello there Jerry  Jones your old let me help you across  the street no let me walk in for poor  people wait what's this  I want you a helicopter cool that work  so long dorky more like Andrew odd lucky  [Music]